hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts new pathways for
recovery of function following paralysis
presented by our keynote speaker dr.
Reggie Edgerton we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by LaBrie the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning I'm Cristina Jewel elaborate
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or you may use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinars and best offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on this to e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I'd like to
introduce dr. Reggie Edgerton dr.
Edgerton received his PhD in exercise
physiology from Michigan State
University a master's from University of
Iowa and BS from East Carolina
University he is currently the director
of the neuromuscular research laboratory
and a distinguished professor of the
department's of interpretive biology and
physiology neurobiology and neurosurgery
he has been teaching and conducting
research at UCLA for over 40 years his
research is focused on how the neural
networks in the lumbar spinal cord of
mammals including humans regained
oh love standing stepping and voluntary
control of fine movements after
paralysis and how these pins motor
functions be modified by chronically
imposing activity dependent
interventions after spinal cord injury
please join me in welcoming dr. Reggie
Edgerton I will now turn the
presentation over to him
good morning it's a pleasure to have the
opportunity to present a lecture to you
at this virtual symposium that is being
organized by lab roots and I'm going to
talk to you about some of the newer
findings related to the possibility of
recovering from paralysis the title of
the talk new pathways to recover
function after paralysis first of all
I'd like to inform you they have a
conflict of interest because some of the
work that we're doing is requiring us to
develop technologies and I'm part owner
of a company that's developing the
technology so that we can take advantage
of some of the findings that we have
reported in this slide you will see an
animal that is stepping on a treadmill
this animal is completely paralyzed
without the interventions that we have
been developing and this animal even
though there's no input from the brain
this animal can step forward can step
backwards and as you see in the third
video to the right you'll see the animal
actually gradually adjusting the step
stepping so that the animal can step
sideways so this is all occurring
without any input from the brain so what
I would like for you to think about is
to what extent can this level of
automaticity that's built into the
spinal circuitry that is control in this
movement to what extent would that be
possible to happen in human subjects so
what I'm going to talk about in this
lecture is the progress that has been
made not only in our laboratory but in
other laboratories that suggest that
there's considerable potential in the
human spinal cord and the whole nervous
system of the human that will enable us
to take advantage of a considerable
amount of this automaticity and I will
also try to tell you to what degree we
have some idea of how this is possible
so the automaticity is the key concept
here and the question that I'd like for
you to think about is where does this
automaticity come from this automaticity
comes from to a major extent from the
spinal networks the spinal networks
alone have remarkable capability to
process information now this particular
slide is to illustrate why and how we've
come to recognize some of these
phenomenon in in the spinal cord and
it's largely because many of the the
strategies for controlling movement have
been derived and developed actually over
millions of years through evolution so
the same processes of neural controller
movement that's present in fish birds
amphibians mammals to a large extent are
very similar now I'd also like to point
out that as a result of this
evolutionary conservation of the neuro
control mechanism the person on the
lower right stand Grill nur has been one
of the leaders in this area he is at the
Karolinska Institute the person down on
the lower left is one of the first
individuals to show that these levels of
automaticity are also present in mammals
now let's take a larger look at where is
the control of movement where does it
occur of course if there's the
individual is uninjured then you have
all of your nervous system to help you
to make all the movements that you do
that is you had the brain you have the
neural circuitry within the spinal cord
and you have the muscles that can
actually generate the movement itself an
injury can be at multiple levels along
the spinal cord but often most of the
injuries of the spinal cord they will
result in no information or some
information coming from the brain to the
spinal circuitry if there's no
information from the brain the question
here is to what extent how much
automaticity can
take advantage of from the spinal cord
and from the muscle itself so our
emphasis has been in this control system
that's within the spinal cord now you
can get some movement by going directly
to the muscles we know that we could put
electrodes in the muscles directly
stimulate and that's a technique that's
common and that's referred to as
functional electrical stimulation
however by going directly to the muscle
you're completely bypassing the very
sophisticated control systems that are
in the spinal cord and that's where our
focus has been again going along the
same concept I'd like for you to think
about the nervous system consisting of
the brain and the spinal cord and
networks throughout the brain and the
spinal cord all highly interconnected so
basically we should be thinking of the
fact that the spinal cord functions as
part of the brain it can do almost a
very large number of the functions that
occur in the brain can also occur in the
spinal cord and again that's the source
of the automaticity that we're trying to
see to what extent we can take advantage
in human subjects with complete
paralysis now to give you an idea of how
some of these idea ideas have evolved
over time it's not been an overnight
recognition that some of these things
that I'm going to show you is possible
it's actually this work has again
occurred in multiple laboratories all
over the world and has been going on for
decades but one of the key things again
is to what extent can we take advantage
of the automaticity that's built into
the spinal circuitry now one of the
concepts and the phenomenon that has
been known for for many years is the
idea of central pattern generation and
that is that these networks within the
spinal cord can generate rhythmic
activity without any input from the
brain or actually without any input from
the sensory system but here you see
sensory system and cpgs
are projecting to the automaticity but
this is really just part of the sources
of the automaticity but there are two
very important sources as you will see
as we move forward the other important
finding that we found over time is that
the spinal circuitry can learn so many
of the mechanisms that is that are used
in the in the brain itself to learn
different events this learning can also
occur in the spinal cord and therefore
that enables us to use training and
rehabilitation physical therapy as
another tool to take advantage of this
automaticity so the spinal learning is
very important and we'll see some
evidence of that now as we went further
we've also recognized the importance of
this concept of neuromodulation
neuromodulation is where we can use a
number of different interventions to
change the physiological state the
functional state of the spinal cord your
brain physiological state and the spinal
cord changes continuously but we can
change it so that it is more likely to
be able to stand or step particularly
after paralysis so the idea of
neuromodulation is also imported because
when we stimulate we're not actually
inducing the movement you see in able
inversus inducing we change the
physiological state so this circuitry
can now stand and step and generate
voluntary activity we enable it to do it
we don't induce it to do that so and the
importance of the sensory system is is
is great because you just saw an example
of spinal rats that can can perform
rather complex movements now the other
thing in the human as we progress to
some of the human experiments what we
find is a little unexpected is that the
ability to control movement voluntarily
that is the after a clinically complete
motor complete spinal cord injury
individuals have been able to regain
connect
from the brain to the spinal cord and
regaining this connectivity was a big
surprise to us but now looking back on
it we we think we might have a handle on
how this how this is happening and then
the other thing that is happening during
the chronic treatment of these
individuals that are completely
paralyzed completely paralyzed for more
than a year that there are changes in
the autonomic system the autonomic
system is a part of the central nervous
system that controls things like blood
pressure blood flow bladder function
bowel function sexual function all of
these systems that we never think about
having to control because it's done
automatically and this is referred to as
the autonomic nervous system now where
is this occurring this is a longitudinal
cross section of the spinal cord of a
cat actually and you see circled in red
the neurons the inter neurons in the
middle and coming from the top the
dorsum of the spinal cord sensory
information is coming in and be
projecting to these inter neurons and
these inter neurons are the ones that's
performing this amazing complicated
interpretation of the sensory
information coming that's helping the
helping the animals what you've seen so
far to step in to stand and perform the
voluntary activity so this is a key area
that we need to know a lot more about
exactly who and how these inner neurons
are doing this so again going back to
the idea we almost all of our movements
are made automatically you don't have to
think about the details of which muscles
you're activating to perform a given
movement so why and my hands are
flailing around I have no idea how which
motor pools I'm activated is just the
combination of muscles that is that are
activated that's defining the movement
and this again is done relatively
automatic as a result of taking
advantage of all the sensory input to
the spinal cord all of our sensory
systems
to the motor system and therefore we
have different sources of control now
just to carry further on this
automaticity start to start in this
slide
you
okay so what you saw when the point that
I want to make out of this is in this
structure there's a very simple signal
that turns this this structure from a
sit into a standing position there's a
bench in front of it and if you sit on
this bench this structure will begin to
stand up the point is a very simple
signal with a relatively complex
structure that's attached to this signal
can generate complicated movements so
again this is another basic idea that we
need to keep in mind in trying to
understand how this is working so now
getting back to what is more
specifically what is central pattern
generation central pattern generation is
demonstrated here this is the output
from nerves going to flexor and extensor
muscles but on the top channel where you
see the output from a single interneuron
and this inter neuron is active at the
same time during the quote step cycle
during what's referred to as fictive
locomotion because there's really no
movement but there's alternating
activation of the nerves that's going to
these different muscles this can go on
for hours just by placing a given
combination the appropriate combination
of pharmacological agents will induce
this rhythmic activity and without any
sensory information and without any
information from the brain so the
central pattern generators the networks
that have the intrinsic capability to
oscillate in flexor and extensor like
patterns without phasic input from the
brain or peripheral apparence now okay
where does this leave us in terms of the
automaticity the automaticity yes some
is built into the central pattern
generator but if you look over to the
left you see the first circle represents
the circuitry within the spinal cord and
then you have input from the brain from
the top and sensory information just
feed it in from the right and the
combination of those sources the central
pattern generator the brain
and the sensory information is behind
all of this control of the movement
normally now if you eliminate input from
the brain as shown in the middle and you
also eliminate the sensory information
this system can generate central pattern
generation and and oscillate as I've
already shown you but if you look to the
far right you see if you eliminate
information from the brain but you
preserve these sensory information
coming from proprioception and skin then
this system can perform many types of
activities not only can it oscillate but
it can step with full weight-bearing it
can adjust the loading speed it can
adjust the mechanical Turtle Bay
perturbation for example if you're if
the animal because has some obstacle
that's in front of them but in addition
the system can learn so it has the
making of everything that we would need
theoretically in order to in order to to
take advantage of this automaticity in
human subjects now here at the top you
see a list of different sources of
sensory information which now we know is
very important over on the left you see
the cortex we tend to think that most of
our movement is controlled by the cortex
but my point here is most of this
information a related to controlling
movement comes relatively automatic as a
result of the sensory information going
to the spinal cord and to to the brain
as well when when there is no injury but
the cortex certainly is it has an
imported influence and can can control
but it doesn't have to control it can
leave some of the control in fact a lot
of the control to automatic mechanisms
within this largely within the spinal
cord to control movement so the other
factors I'd like to show the basis of
the concept of spinal learning when
animal when if the animal is completely
spinal Isaac's phone cord is cut at a
mid thoracic region and then if you
train the animal to step
what they will do over a period of weeks
has learned a step better and better
more accurately better coordinated
stepping so you see the top line is is
how fast the animals can step when they
have been trained to step and then the
lower line represents those animals that
have been spine alized and treated the
same but they have not been trained to
set so this is one of the first
indications that the spinal cord can
learn caring further with this can you
teach them to stand yes we can teach
them the stand and over a period of
weeks they can learn to stand for a
longer period of time or without falling
down and losing their ability to support
so we know that we the the we if we can
engage these circuits the circuits that
are engaged can learn and it basically
learns what we teach it now this is
another example of learning and when
someone is practicing a skill a new
skill you become better and better at
performing this skill you see the top
three lines are examples of the
trajectory of the pawl of spinal rats
that are stepping on the treadmill and
you see there's quite a bit of noise in
the lower three rows in it with the pink
background you see animals each of these
animals have been trained to step so you
can see the accuracy and consistency of
the stepping is greatly improved as a
result of the training and this tells
you how imported it is to engage the
circuitry so that it can relearn how to
perform these tasks this is another
example of that in the top you see the
EMG burst patterns that are somewhat
effective in stepping but not very
effective and then in the bottom you see
more well-organized burst of EMG and
that's reflected in the graphs to the
right which shows those graphs to the
right show that flexor and extensor
muscles have a much higher incidence of
co-contraction where the
activation in both flexion and extension
at the same time but as these animals
are trained the incidence of this Coco
contraction decreases considerably and
we think this is one of the the
phenomenon that is typical of realigning
now let's go to the neuromodulation of
the physiological state of the spinal
networks and in in this case what you're
seeing is an animal that has been
trained to stand complete spinal
transaction and has not taken the step
for three months and you can see when
put on the treadmill unlike the rats
what you saw earlier this animal cannot
step at all he's been trained only to
stand but if you give this animal
strychnine strychnine this inhibits the
spinal circuitry gets it more excitable
and now the sensory information going to
the spinal cord enables this animal to
step full weight-bearing over a range of
speeds and this has this change in the
physiological state of the spinal cord
has changed within 30 minutes for three
months this end of this individual cat
has not has never taken a weight-bearing
step so again showing the importance of
the physiological state and the
neuromodulation and engage in these
circuits that have become relatively non
responsive again now let's go back to
this slide where we can appreciate it a
little more again remember what we're
trying to do to find out to what extent
this level of automaticity with the not
only central pattern generation but the
sensory information is available the
sensory information going from coming
from the hind limbs is being is is
derived simply from the direction of the
movement of the treadmill relative to
the orientation of the body so all of
this sensory and proprioceptive
information is conserving as a complete
control system now how is this happening
obviously
it has to be something like this if you
look at the top you see the F foot would
be in the sensory ensemble that's going
to the motor neurons and the inter
neurons when the animal stepping forward
versus stepping sideways and stepping
backwards so each one of these ensembles
of sensory information is sending unique
information to the inter neurons and the
inter neurons are interpreting this
these complex sensory signals and then
making a decision to to activate a given
set of motor neurons and the given set
of motor neurons that are active will
define whether the animal stepping
forward backwards or sideways so
obviously we'd like to know who these
entered neurons are and we don't really
know very much about these inter neurons
we've been trying to find this out for
more than four decades and made
considerable progress but still a long
ways for understanding this concept as
the animal is moving from walking from
one side to the other for example it
will activate different combinations of
inter neurons and different combinations
of inter neurons will activate different
combinations of motor neurons and again
that's where you get the forward
backward and side words stepping now
another concept related to this is that
that there's a couple of ways of looking
at how the spinal cord is processing
this information one way you could say
each a pixel on this photograph
represents an important piece of
information that is telling the spinal
cord about that particular pixel and
that is a specific signal for the spinal
cord to do something but let me suggest
to you if you look at it this way if you
take all the sensory systems and put
them together what the spinal cord is
really trying to do is grasp what the
total picture is the big picture so if
you have all of the information from all
of the sensor systems that are coming
from the hind limb then the spinal cord
can see exactly where it is and what it
should be doing next so it's the
combination of all of this sensory
information that's given a specific
signal to the spinal cord as to what the
current state is and what needs what's
most likely going to happen next I often
make the comment that in these spinal
animals what is illustrated is the
sensory information that's coming back
to the spinal cord if it's an uninjured
individual the same sensory information
is coming back but it's just being nice
to the brain to tell the brain that it
already knows what it's going to do
again this built-in automaticity is
something that the big question is to
what degree is this automaticity built
into the human nervous system so at this
point over decades of research we're
beginning to think that maybe it's time
to try some of these things in
individuals with complete paralysis so
it could start on this light
you
okay so what was the point of that the
point was that this is really where our
thinking was about 15 years ago when we
were first beginning to learn that
individuals with spinal injuries could
could learn to step on the treadmill but
those individuals where we had had that
success was primarily with individuals
with severe but not complete injuries
now this work was done in collaboration
with Susan Harkema when she was at UCLA
and this was the beginning of our effort
to transfer our dog tried to transfer
our knowledge from from the animal
experiments to the humans now here is an
example of a response by an individual
with a complete paralysis to the far
left and then to the far right is a
normal individual completely intact so
what has happened in individuals
stepping on the treadmill and with the
complete paralysis of course there's
some assistance of the movement of the
legs as you saw in the previous video
but what you see is as the more loading
is placed on the legs when the
individual is is stepping you will see
that the EMG activity is activated more
you see a very similar pattern in the
normal individual so this is another
illustration of automaticity we're just
with the sensory information is telling
the spinal cord how to modulate the
activation of the muscles to perform the
movement so this is another example
that's telling us look there's maybe the
nervous system that's controlling the
movement in in humans is not that
different from from the rat and the
mouse and the cat obviously every all
that some details are different in every
animal but here you can see that if you
stimulate the lumbosacral region of the
spinal cord of a spinal rat you see
these alternating patterns of activity
of multiple muscles flexors and
extensors of the hind limbs and over on
the right this is a
spinal cord injured subject that is
completely paralyzed and you can see a
very similar pattern
so there's increase in information that
there's a lot of common elements so it
at this point we became confident enough
to let's say let's try this in in human
subjects and this was the collaboration
between colleagues at Caltech and with
Joel Burdick and with dr. Susan Harkema
at University of Louisville at this
point and then and in our group at UCLA
so we implanted four subjects and began
to see to what extent we could recover
some of these functions now the way we
did this is the we use the present
technology that's available to the same
technology as used for suppressing pain
in the in the spinal cord many subjects
with spinal cord injury have a lot of
pain and so we thought that even though
this device was designed to do something
else and it didn't have all the
properties we would like based on our
animal experiments we still thought it
would be good enough so we could
determine proof of principle it could
this possibly work in human subjects and
so in the middle you see a 16 electrode
array that's that's overlaying a couple
of the vertebrae in the lumbar region
and this the this electrode array was
implanted to cover most of the
lumbosacral segments that's imported in
standing and stepping and one of the
first things that we learned is the
individuals could learn to stand just
like the cats learn to stand it took a
little longer
initially for these individuals to learn
to stand but they could learn to stand
the this individual was standing in a
standing frame trained every five days a
week for for almost a year and when the
stimulation is off the person cannot
stand at all the person can stand with
the stimulation on and as you see to the
bottom and to the right of the graph
the the line that sent black this is the
amount of time that the individual could
stand completely independently without
any help and this is approximately
twenty to twenty minutes over the time
that they learn but it took a while for
the spinal cord to relearn how to
process the sensory information now in
the next three slides you're going to
see several things you're going to see
an individual that has regained
voluntary control that had been
previously paralyzed when you turn the
stimulator on the individual we asked
the individual to oscillate the legs
continuously flex the legs in multiple
times and you'll see in the first video
approximately thirty contractions and
then the individual breaks the cable but
then continues to contract and you can
see again the burst and EMG that
continues for up to approximately 60
contractions so this is demonstrating
the return of voluntary control the
somehow the brain has reorganized and
the lumbosacral circuitry has
reorganized so that the two can talk to
each other somehow so now the
individuals have regained significant
voluntary control in the next in the
following panel the third panel that
you're going to see as an individual
that's not only learn to stand but
you'll see has learned to gain some
ability to balance so the spinal cord
also automatically
modifies the physiological state of
these circuits so that you can maintain
your posture without falling and so this
is shown in in this video so could show
these three video clips
so without disability to have some
balance to be able to throw the ball and
catch it the person would would fall if
they didn't have some degree of balance
but obviously it's not completely
completely normal now going back to the
oscillatory activity this is to show the
enabling concept and the blue line there
represents the 30 Hertz signal
continuous tonic signal that's being
applied to the lumbosacral spinal cord
through this electrode array but the
bursts of activity just above that is
what is generated from the the the
subjects intent to contract so he is
that's the voluntary aspect of it so you
only get the movement of when he intends
to move so this is the spinal cord is
being stimulated to enable it to respond
to the voluntary control that's coming
from the brain and the reorganization of
the spinal circuitry that has occurred
that's also helped it to enable this
movement so you can you can see that
that this will you see the contractions
will occur on the bottom you'll see the
relative forces that are generated
within a motor pool and you only see the
movement when the a burst of EMG
activity is generated voluntarily by the
subject now in further looking into this
how they regain voluntary control
there's a motor threshold that I
mentioned before and I will talk more
about later but here you show in a C in
a graph that at approximately 7 volts
when the stimulation got up to a 7 volts
the individual was able to regain
voluntary movement in the first subject
that was implanted this did not occur
until six to seven months after the
implant but in the subsequent subjects
given that we knew this was possible now
other subjects and we became a little
bit smarter and doing these experiments
and learning how to stimulate these
subjects regaining voluntary control
much faster so the point here is that
once you get the threshold you increase
the voltage you can get further more and
more force but you get to a point where
if you stimulate too much the
stimulation interferes and overcomes the
control system so you have to have a
modulation that's getting the
excitability level of these networks
within a relatively narrow window it has
to be above a threshold but it can't be
too much so that's what we're trying to
attain in all these subjects when
they're being trained conceptually it
looks like this to the left is an
individual that would be uninjured and
you see that there's no problem getting
above the motor threshold the hash line
if the individual is injured you can't
get to that hash line if you're below
that hash line you're completely
paralyzed you don't know how completely
you are paralyzed actually you don't
know how close you are to that hash line
but we do know if we stimulate we can
provide this background excitation and
then the person can have enough residual
activity it appears to get above the
threshold once you get above the
threshold you've engaged circuitry that
has not been active before and this
circuitry can begin to reorganize and
improve function with continued practice
so another way of looking at this if you
have a little bit of input going to the
motor neurone it's still not enough to
get to the threshold you get another
source of input is not but if you can
get a total amount of input is enough to
get above this threshold then you have
gone gone from being parrot completely
paralyzed to not being completely
paralyzed now here's a basically a basic
experiment that was done in in rats
where in the the rats were stimulated at
a rate that was below the motor
threshold 20% below the motor threshold
so it in itself did not have any impact
on the act
pivoting on the left and the two columns
of to the left you'll see activity in
one of the muscles the soleus muscle
when the rat is just resting and in the
cage over on the right we turn the
stimulator on and you still don't see
much activity but the point is when they
are playing around in the cage with the
20% less than motor threshold you get an
amazing amount of activity and and
perform it so standing and quadrupedal
stepping and so forth and then the total
amount of activity when the spinal cord
is being stimulated is five times
greater than it is if this if the animal
is not being simulated below this
threshold so we think this has very
important implications as to how we may
be able to use this new modulation not
only in the clinic but in the home so
basically what the stimulation is doing
on an analogy might be it's just it's
serving as a hearing aid it's amplifying
the potential of the sensory information
that's going back to the spinal cord
another way of looking at this is that
you have a normal baseline level
potential that's below the motor
threshold and then to activate and get
forces you have to activate these motor
neurons and to do that there's no
problem if you're uninjured they get to
that motor threshold you can activate a
given set of motor neurons now after an
injury we think that that baseline
activity goes way down and as a result
with the same amount of input it still
would not be able you would not be able
to reach the motor threshold so so again
with the oscillatory activity you can
easily get across the threshold if
you're uninjured but if you're injured
the threshold goes down with the same
amount of input you will still not be
able to reach the threshold and
therefore you're completely paralyzed
and then but if you can elevate we
the electrical enabling motor control as
we refer to again you transform from
paralysis to one of incomplete paralysis
and then the same thing I'll go quickly
over this is if you if you look at a
step cycle the proprioceptive
information is driving the system
flexion and extension of quite readily
but after an injury the threshold is
further away from what the baseline is
and you cannot do anything but with the
stimulation again now we can enable this
proprioception to drive the flexion and
extension so another way of looking at
driving this concept home pretty hard
here is that what we have to do is
modulate the excitability of these enter
neurons the motor pools are just doing
what they're told by the inter neurons
and so you have a background level of
activity that's going to the motor
neurons and then you can add stimulation
and pharmacological activation and
that's enough to get over this motor
threshold using a combination of ways to
modulate the excitability now I'm going
to there's an another technique that
we've developed in the meantime we've
referred to as a transcutaneous
stimulation rather than relying on an
implant we can take electrodes and just
place on the skin over the lumbosacral
area or the cervical area and can I get
similar responses as what's been seen as
epidural electrodes these five subjects
that were studied all of them had
complete paralysis motor complete
paralysis some had some evidence of
sensory information and would be
considered in Asia B now we place these
subjects that have been paralyzed for
more than a year with their legs
extended over the table so they can
oscillate we're seeing if they can
oscillate in a rhythmic pattern and then
here you will see in this series of
movements you'll see in the first time
the individual is being treated with
this transcutaneous stimulation
voluntarily you'll see virtually no
movement you will see some wiggling of
the leg but it's basically with the
subject moving their upper body and
translating this momentum to the lower
leg but then when you ask the person to
generate voluntary movement in the
presence of stimulation you will see
first the stimulation effect voluntary
then stimulation and then voluntary plus
stimulation and you will see that with
voluntary + stimulation in the first
session there's some evidence of
voluntary contact and this voluntary
contact from the brain to the spinal
cord and this is after more than a year
of complete paralysis so start the video
now the individuals were trained for 18
sessions and you will see before and
after training
you
you
so what you saw is a significant
increase in the movement of the limbs
and what you see in this particular
graph is the range of motion in the knee
that was recorded under these different
conditions in the first session on the
far left you see that even in that first
session when you combine voluntary
activity plus stimulation you see
there's some influence of the voluntary
and then after four sessions you see
even more but on the fifth session what
you see that's really encouraging is
that with voluntary activity along with
voluntary endpoints alone the amount of
movement that they could generate is not
significantly different from that that's
combined with stimulation so this tells
us that there must have been significant
reorganization of both the super spinal
and spinal networks that's allowing this
to happen so and this occurred with
approximately one hour treatment once a
week for 18 weeks so again we don't know
how much further we can take this and
we're obviously using similar techniques
for too and have results that the
transcutaneous stimulation is also
effective in facilitating standing and
and to some degree stepping and other
secondary effects that we will talk
about later but another experiment that
we did we think is is eventually going
to be more and more important with time
as the technology improves an
exoskeleton devices here we've combined
stimulation with the exoskeleton and we
our first subject that we have tested
and studied fairly extensively is that
this individual had already practiced
and knew how to work in this exoskeleton
very well so it's basically at a
baseline so when we added the
stimulation we could we would know what
in additional
the additional functions that might
emerge as a result of the stimulation
plus stepping in the exoskeleton and
those results also are highly
encouraging so here's an example of what
the individual looks like when they're
stepping you can't really tell when the
stimulator is on and when it's not but
this is just to give you an indication
of what it looks like women a completely
paralyzed individual is stepping in the
treadmill and this is after he had had a
number of treatments I don't recall
exactly the number here but he could
already walk before we ever started to
study him but the real question is that
we want to answer is to what degree can
he recover voluntary control and have
some impact on the robotic device so it
can perform some of the work and the
robotic device does not have to perform
all of the work okay so start the video
now in the next video you're going to
see our first test of whether he had
regained voluntary control of flexing
the legs similar to what you saw in a
previous subject with epidural
stimulation again this is the
transcutaneous stimulation and what
you're going to see first the subject is
asked to flex the knee and without the
stimulator on and he will not be able to
turn the stimulator on and he still is
not moving the leg but if you turn the
stimulator on and then give him the
signal to try to move the leg he tries
to flex and you will see what happens
so so this individual had been trained
for five sessions had been paralyzed for
more than four years when this
experiment was done so show the video
you
so you can only imagine what it might
feel like to an individual paralyzed for
four years and this is the first time
they've been able to move of course we
don't know how much improvement can
occur in terms of voluntary control
but again this is transcutaneous
stimulation combined with with working
in this exoskeleton and other very
interesting results were found with
respect to the ability to to modulate
cardiovascular function the heart rate
could go up much higher to a normal
level of sweating would occurred and and
so there's a range of activities that
are occurring relatively relatively
quickly as a result of the
transcutaneous stimulation and the
activity dependent plasticity that's
occurring so the obvious question also
is can be general modulate the cervical
spinal cord those individuals that are
quadriplegic and could benefit from just
a little bit of improvement for example
this is do it slide is to illustrate
that just a little bit of work on the
x-axis can result in mark changes in
performance when you have nothing to
work with to begin with as opposed to an
athlete that's highly skilled it takes a
lot more work to get a relatively small
amount so my point is is that even
though to the uninjured some of these
changes may appear to be relatively
small they are highly significant to
individuals that have no function and
there is significant for the caregivers
as they are for the subject so here is
an example of changes in the ability to
generate forces with a hand grip before
and after four weeks of approximately
one to one-and-a-half hours of treatment
twice a week
play the video please
you
you
so what you saw is within those 15
sessions of treatment the amount of
force that was gained is somewhere
between five and ten fold and these
relatively quote small changes I can
assure you that they're not small to the
individual that's regaining this level
of control the first amount of force
that was generated was less than a half
of a Newton and then going to almost
almost two or three Newton's of force
and we're now trying to associate this
with other quality of life functions and
making some progress on this which is
encouraging which I an example of that
is in in this is another more recent
subject that's been treated similar with
transcutaneous stimulation and this is
just a demonstration of one task there's
multiple tasks like this that we are
observing now start the video that
you'll see that this level of function
you
cervical region is affecting more than
those muscles that are just associated
with grip they're also affecting the
more proximal muscles which eight which
enables the person to move the the limbs
in a more controlled way so they can add
the control of the proximal muscles to
the distal muscles and get even more
function but in addition almost all of
the subjects are showing significant
improvement in trunk control so there's
multiple physiological systems that are
responding so now let me try to give you
some idea of the scope of what is we see
before us number one
we think that there's different
pathologies that that can benefit from
these types of interventions and we're
trying those and have some data related
to these first four items on the left
but in addition this effect is even
amplified more when you think of
multiple functions that can be affected
by this modulation and then when you
think about the possibility of taking
some of these interventions and
combining them with other interventions
that are being developed it provides
some reason to have some encouragement
that we can really take this much
further than we have been able to so far
so we would have to be fairly optimistic
at this point I think at this point we
certainly can say reclaiming a highly
functional life after paralysis is well
within our quote grasp and I think these
things will translate into greater
quality of life we are just at the
beginning of understanding these new
phenomenons that have been uncovered and
so the challenge is going to be to see -
how how far we can take these
interventions with respect to how far a
given individual can improve
and what kind of injuries are going to
be responsive to these types of
interventions so the evolution of the
underlying concepts I've talked about
the automaticity of movement based on
the brain stem stimulation the central
pattern generation sensory processing
the modulation of the physiological
state so so the that gives us the
enabling levels of neuromodulation and
this can be done through electrical
stimulation and pharmacological
stimulation and the all-important
plasticity that's occurring as a result
of the learning the activity dependent
plasticity so and we we need to be able
to combine these new physiological
phenomenon in concepts with the
technology there needs to be a very
tight integration of development of new
technologies that can also help us to
take advantage of new functions that we
have not seen before
within the brain and the spinal cord
after after injury so I think we can
easily say that the previously
unrecognized potential level of recovery
of motor function via neuromodulation in
neuroplasticity is highly significant
and I think we can look ahead to further
explore these possibilities and I think
we haven't come close to realize in the
real clinical potential this as that's
before us so many individuals have been
imported in and in developing these
experiments over a period of years the
individuals here have been ki from
almost the beginning from the
technological standpoint and from
physiological standpoint down at the
bottom you have Joel dyrdek from Caltech
and then you have Guzman Garron the chef
from from Russia and you have Wynn tyloo
from UCLA the top three
there are from UCLA roland roy your
jaw's amico and Parag add and then we
have multiple scientist in the lab that
has also contributed to these over years
and I talked quite a bit about the work
that we've done in collaboration with
Susan Harkema over in the far right and
Claudia Angela and our own lab manager
Mandi Turner so we've been supported by
a number of organizations of course we
never get enough funding and we think
with more funding we can go even faster
and we hope we'll be able to do that
thank you for listening and I'm open to
answering questions some questions have
been submitted and I can get to those
questions and and answer those at this
time thank you
okay let me I'll read the questions that
have been submitted and and I'll give a
brief answer what are the effects of
spinal stimulation on bladder and bowel
function I didn't have chance to talk
about bowel and bladder function and
other autonomic controls but with both
epidural stimulation and transcutaneous
stimulation were consistently finding
improvement in function of bladder and
bowel function to the extent that the
individuals some of the individuals are
regained the ability to sense how how
filled their bladder is and that is a
very important point to avoid
overfilling of the of the bladder but
not only can they sense it but some of
them have regained the ability to
voluntarily void urine with respect to
bowel we've had reported cases of the
the the ease with which the subject has
with taking care of the bowel function
on a daily basis as improved saving time
can be done more quickly so we have a
number of observations and consistent
enough to convince us that as we learn
how to control this circuitry this
autonomic circuitry we will be able to
take advantage of that automaticity as
well but the degree to which we can do
that remains to be determined but
there's a lot of interest and a lot of
labs that are trying to make some
progress on this because everyone knows
how important this is in the daily life
of those individuals with paralysis a
second question is can the spinal
stimulation device be used at home or in
the clinic only presently the epidural
stimulation device has been used in the
clinic but we got approval with FDA that
the subjects can take it home with very
specific limitations as to how much they
can simulate and what patterns of
stimulation so yes that is happening and
yes that is a very important question
the idea of trying to oh and actually
reaching a higher level function and
then at the end of the study having to
tell the subject okay this is the end of
the study but we don't have a device
that you can take home obviously we have
to avoid that for the transcutaneous
stimulation we're in the process of
building the device and trying to get
FDA approval for this device the intent
is as rapidly as possible and hopefully
as soon as it might be available for
distribution in clinics and use in the
clinics we hope that we will have the
capability of having and develop a
device that will be able to go home this
is essential for for this to be a
practical type of intervention so
certainly that's going to be our goal
and I think it's feasible what will the
spinal stimulation units cost there's a
big difference in the implantable system
and the transcutaneous system the
implantable system when by the time
you're combined all the hospital costs
you're maybe even in the range of a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars just
to get through the implant and and to
buy the device with the transcutaneous
stimulation we don't know how much that
device will cost but it may be somewhere
initially around ten to twenty thousand
dollars but with the possibility that
that could come down substantially
depending on many factors in the from
the commercial standpoint and when will
these devices be available to patients
well the device on one device that's
designed for pain is already available
if you get approval from FDA they use it
accordingly
there are a number of places that are
trying to develop smaller stimulators
for epidural stimulation and our lab is
one of those individuals individual labs
that's doing so and
our track a plan is to be able to have a
device that we think will be far
superior to what's presently available
available but it's going to take five to
six years and a lot more money to get
that to the point where it'd be
commercially available we think on the
other hand with the transcutaneous
stimulation that that device with a
acquiring adequate support this device
can be available within to the two and a
half years and we're obviously looking
forward to that day what other benefits
do you expect from spinal stimulation
with the therapy help reduce medical
costs we certainly think it's going to
reduce medical costs because it has
these multiple secondary effects you
might call secondary but the very
important effects related to autonomic
function we think that the the data in
the end we don't have these data now but
we want to get these data as rapidly as
possible we think the data are going to
show that by the time you consider all
the cost of the intervention itself
that's going to be far cheaper than not
having this intervention because of the
medical complications without having it
those medical complications the cost of
that over a period of lifetime is going
to be far greater than the initial cost
of the intervention that is our what we
are thinking at the time we don't have
the evidence to show that but that is
some evidence that we need to get can
the same device be used for hand
rehabilitation and leg rehabilitation
well not quite because you the functions
that you use with your hand and with
your legs will be different but both of
them are basing at the same time same
frame framework in that
we are trying to take advantage of the
activity dependent plasticity so we've
got to get this the cervical spinal
networks that are involved in a given
movement we have to have the apparatus
that's going to to enable that movement
to occur but we also want those devices
to have feedback to the subjects so they
will know how they're performing so
there's lots of room for improvement and
specialized devices and I think that's
going to be part of the new thinking of
how to fully take advantage of these
types of interventions so anyway I think
I'll stop there and thank you very much
for your attention and hope you enjoyed
this special virtual symposium in
neuroscience thank you
you